one consideration for making a tasty
dumpling is maximizing the amount of
filling for a given size wrapper without
it falling apart a team of researchers
applied the same principle but instead
of making dumplings they came up with a
fast way of making capsules by wrapping
a splashing liquid drop with a thin
sheet in this demonstration a drop of
oil is released at a specific height
onto a thin polymer sheet floating on a
pool of water immediately after impact
as the droplet sinks into the pool and
air pocket forms reaches a maximum depth
and then retracts back to the surface
when the air pocket snaps back the sheet
wraps around the drop forming the
capsule the sequence of events happens
very fast in just milliseconds once the
wrapped oil separates from the water
surface the capsule sinks under gravity
the whole process begins with the thin
polymer sheets which are cut into
various designs the wrappers 2d shape
determines the resulting 3d shapes of
the capsules the final encapsulated
shape is a result of the interplay
between the size and shape of the
wrapper and the size of the droplet The
Wrap stays in place because of surface
tension and differences between the
interior and exterior liquids the
interior liquid cools on the wrapper to
maximize the covered area because of
this the edges of the wrappings don't
overlap or leave an opening these
near-perfect seams reduce leakage and
slow down evaporation the capsules are
tough enough to be prodded yet they
still revert back to their original
shape researchers demonstrated that the
wrappings worked with several different
drop and environment pairings and the
wrapper could even be layered
one day this scaleable rapping recipe
could be used to make multifunctional
capsules that help preserve the liquids
contained inside and target them for
delivery to specific cells in the body
[Music]
you